[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
as to the fifth count of the information
gage gross courts we the jury find the
defendant kyle avery kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
defendant kyle rainhouse is found not
guilty on all charges we are live in
kenosha with a reaction to the verdict
and the death of ahmad armory trial with
that understanding
we rest all of the evidence that will be
presented in this case has been
presented closing arguments loom in the
racially charged case plus a not guilty
plea for a former trump advisor what
criminal contempt of congress charges
mean for steve bannon and later a look
ahead at the federal trial of gelane
maxwell the socialite accused of
facilitating jeffrey epstein in sexually
assaulting minors law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with co-host
terry austin it was the verdict heard
across the country as accused kenosha
shooter kyle rainhouse is found not
guilty on all counts angel levy was in
the courtroom as the verdict was read
she joins us now live outside the
courthouse and anjanette what can you
tell us about the first moments after
rin has heard the jury found him not
guilty
brian it was incredibly tense inside
that courtroom kyle rittenhouse began to
cry as did his mother and other family
members as those five not guilty
verdicts were read also rittenhouse
collapsed as the clerk read that final
not guilty
first count of the verdict
joseph rosenbaum read the jury define
the defendant kyle h rittenhouse not
guilty
as to the second count of the
information richard mcginnis we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the third count of the information
unknown mail we the jury find the
defendant kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
as to the fourth count of the
information anthony huber we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the fifth count of the information
gage gross courts we the jury find the
defendant kyle a
kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
members of the jury are these your
unanimous verdicts
is there anyone who does not agree with
the verdicts as read
would you wish the jury pulled
okay
okay folks your job is done
now after those verdicts were read we
spoke with kyle rittenhouse's lead
defense attorney mark richards he talked
about what it was like to hear all of
those not guilty verdicts and what kyle
rittenhouse said to him afterwards
he thanked me he was relieved i i didn't
see kyle's reaction
until i got back to my office and they
played it on television you know he's
sitting to my left i knew that he went
down but i didn't see it
and he i mean he
almost passed out
there's no way two ways about it corey
and
natalie had to grab him and put him back
in his seat and
you know he knew going into that room
that he was either going to prison
probably for the rest of his life or
walking out a free man
i wouldn't want to be in that position
he thanked me
and we said we'd get together and talk
about it after we've had some time to
reflect and
settle down
he wanted to get out of here
because of security issues and things
like that and
that's what happened
the family members of the two men shot
and killed by kyle rittenhouse anthony
huber and joseph rosenbaum they were
sitting right behind me and they held
hands and cried quietly as those not
guilty verdicts were read meanwhile
outside of the courthouse here we heard
from people on both sides of this case
people supporting kyle rittenhouse and
we also heard from those who
supported a conviction in this case one
of those people was jacob blake's uncle
justin blake and jacob blake of course
is the man who was shot by kenosha
police in august of 2020 which sparked
that unrest where kyle rittenhouse shot
the three men
and some of the other people we spoke
with say they feel this is a dark day
they didn't charge the officer to shot
my nephew seven times in the back so in
the back of our mind we knew you're in a
city where things can go way wrong
and they did they should have arrested
this young man when he hit the
illegal fire
so the mayor the police chief the
sheriffs and the people who was running
the military that night has blood on
their hands i think that this is one of
the darkest days in american history
this isn't just about kenosha or
wisconsin we just legalized vigilantism
vigilantism is sport killing
now as i mentioned we also spoke with
supporters of kyle rittenhouse one man
actually drove to wisconsin from omaha
nebraska to show his support
you came here to support kyle
rittenhouse
yeah actually i came here to support
justice
that's the specific reason i'm here and
i knew that he was on the side of
justice from watching the trial from all
the information that i was able to
gather throughout the plethora of news
channels watching the trial
i just believe that justice would be
served and exactly what happened
happened
now after a brief shoving match out here
on the courthouse steps things have been
largely peaceful meanwhile the kenosha
county district attorney's office led by
michael gravely released a statement
saying we respect the jury verdict and
the privilege of self-defense remains a
contentious issue in our current times
the da's office is asking for the public
to accept these verdicts peacefully and
not to resort to violence brian
thanks anjanet joining us today is
defense attorney casia early and terry
austin casey reactions to the verdict
and how do you think we got here
we got here for two separate reasons i
would say that a part of the verdict was
reached because the jury obviously
had a choice did they believe kyle
ridden house or do they believe that the
victims were actually victims and i
believe that
we live in in my opinion two separate
americas because the facts were clear
the evidence was clear however the jury
decided to
acquit mr ridden house on all the
charges we do have to respect the jury's
decision but i respectfully disagree
with that verdict now terry an acquittal
can come from a prosecution losing a
case defense winning it or just the
facts of the case what do you think it
was here
no question brian binger lost this case
he overcharged and he underprepared he
should have focused on those lesser
included charges he didn't do that until
the very end and he should have given
kyle rittenhouse some credit credit for
cleaning that graffiti credit for
helping people medically because he did
do those things he focused too much on
making him look like a vigilante making
him look completely intentional and he
should have also focused on some of this
was reckless no matter what you think
you should not have a 17 year old
carrying an ar-15 and using it the way
he did so i think he lost that case
interesting now and jeanette where does
kyle rain house go from here
well you know it's really interesting
brian he testified during the trial that
he's currently studying nursing
and we had known before that he was a
police cadet at the gray's lake police
department we don't know if he's hoping
to maybe go into law enforcement
now that he's been acquitted we just
don't know but he was studying nursing
during the trial so
we're waiting to hear more from him and
his family spokesperson about what
happens with him next right now i'm
assure you he is breathing a huge sigh
of relief absolutely thank you for that
reporting there internet we knew you
were alive inside the court could only
get that perspective from your great uh
investigation and great work there thank
you very much
still ahead on law and crime daily
former trump adviser steve bannon pleads
not guilty to the criminal contempt
charges in the january 6 investigation
but first the defense makes another
mistrial motion in the death of a mod
arborete trial after the break we hear
from both sides
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
we are going to make sure that we find
justice in this case the three men
charged will now stand trial i told him
stop stop stop till he hit me i had
nothing to do
i just nothing else i could do you're a
pastor buyer coming through not
necessarily
that's my son that shot him i was at the
back of the truck
starting october 18th watch live capital
gavel coverage on the law and crime
network
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
defendants rest their cases in the death
of a mont arbory trial out of glenn
county georgia that's where travis
mcmichael and his father gregory
mcmichael along with their neighbor
william roddy bryan are on trial in the
death of 25 year old aubry all three men
face life in prison if convicted on
charges of malice murder felony murder
and aggravated assault aubry's death
captured the nation's attention after a
video of the february 2020 shooting went
viral gregory and travis and michael
tailed aubry in a pickup truck as he
went for a run near his home he was
unarmed at the time travis mcmichael
eventually shot and killed him claiming
self-defense and citizen arrest a law
that has since been repealed and
replaced on thursday the lawyers for all
three defendants rested their cases
meanwhile hundreds of black pastors
descended on brunswick georgia on
thursday to show support for aubry's
family this came one week after defense
attorney kevin gough called for quote no
more black pastors in the courtroom
after he saw reverend al sharpton
sitting with aubry's family
everybody said
we coming it ain't going to be just a
hundred we gonna double that number and
i think this is the largest
congregation of pastors that i have seen
at a trial in my life so give yourselves
a round of applause
[Applause]
[Applause]
and that's
[Applause]
wherever you are
god is already there
on friday defense attorney kevin goff
responded to that rally calling for a
mistrial in the case the prosecution
countered calling goff's actions
calculated in the end the judge denied
the motion for a mistrial
several well-known nationally revered
figures in our country
speaking literally
at the front door i would guess
five to eight feet probably seven to
eight feet beyond the front door to this
courthouse
i stand on the argument that was
presented i would ask the court to grant
a mistrial of this case based on the
inherent prejudice to mr bryant mr goff
is a brilliant
lawyer
these briefs that he has filed are
detailed and he has filed a ton of
pre-trial briefs that the state has had
to respond to he is very very smart
he is very very calculating and he's a
good lawyer
because
on november 12th he stood up in this
courtroom knowing full well he was on
television
and made comments
about
al sharpton and then black pastors and
colonel sanders all knowing full well it
was being broadcast on television
that was not ineffective assistance of
counsel by any stretch of the
imagination that was strategic he got
the response he wanted because he has
filed a motion a day
based on a continued drumbeat of well
see people are coming and people are
responding but they're responding to
what he did
they're responding to what he
strategically knowingly intelligently
did
so that there would be a response so
that he could then complain of it
back to break down the aubry trial of
defense attorney casia early and terry
austin terry yet another mistrial motion
by kevin gough was this stronger than
the others and what do you think the
plan of all these motions are
you know i think the prosecution was
exactly right there we know goff is
grandstanding he's making a motion a day
he joked with the judge about that it's
no joking matter and the fact that he
compared this to a modern day lynching
he is absolutely biased as far as this
case is concerned and if he really
wanted a motion for a misdraw he could
have focused on the prosecution's
question about the death penalty to one
of the witnesses that question was
inappropriate and that could have been a
grounds for a mistrial so i think
focusing every day on this other issue
is ineffective
now casey a friday is a day of motions
one that stuck out was a citizen's
arrest charge in that a defendant cannot
act on the mere words of another alone
how does that affect the case
well first you have to have reasonable
suspicion you just can't make this
citizen's arrest without knowing or
articulating whether crime has been
committed in the process of being
committed or has been committed so you
can't utilize or rely on what the court
didn't want to say was hearsay evidence
or someone told me that someone did this
so the court was focusing on whether or
not uh the three defendants in this case
had sufficient information other than
this uh
this person or this neighbor told me
that and it's clear that they did not
and in this case mr goff is throwing a
hail mary because he sees that the
prosecution has overwhelming evidence to
secure a conviction so obviously what
was his move to try to get that plea
deal and it was rejected yes interesting
how it's all playing out as we inch
closer and closer to closing arguments
in this case thank you both for your
input coming up on law on crime daily
the federal case of socialite gillane
maxwell looms as the lengthy jury
selection process is underway plus
former trump aide steve bannon appears
in federal court on charges of contempt
of congress but will trump's claim of
executive privilege be enough our legal
analysts break it down after this
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
former trump aide stephen bannon pleads
not guilty to contempt of congress in
connection to the january 6
investigation
on thursday bannon appeared before a
federal judge just days after turning
himself over to the fbi bannon faces
contempt of congress charges after he
defied subpoenas to appear in front of
the so-called january 6 committee and
refused to turn over records leading up
to the insurrection on the u.s capitol
on thursday bannon's team said they plan
to move through the criminal case slowly
citing complex constitutional issues at
play the prosecution countered saying
it's a simple case that can be moved
through quickly meanwhile former
president trump maintains both he and
bannon do not have to release their
january 6 records based on executive
privilege last week a federal court
temporarily sided with trump on this
issue keeping his record sealed for now
or arguments in that trial are set to
begin on november 30th
let's bring back defense attorney kcr
early and co-host terry austin terry the
defense says this is complicated the
prosecution says it's a straightforward
case what do you think
brian it's a straightforward case this
is a simple discovery matter you either
appear for the subpoena and produce the
documents or you don't it is not
complicated what the defense is trying
to say here is that there are
constitutional issues at play and that
trump's formal lawsuit has something to
do with this case and the two are not
related to each other and the defense is
also saying that they want to identify
their witnesses well discovery doesn't
have anything to do with the witnesses
they can do that later down the line and
judge nichols just wants the case to
move forward he's already indicated that
and i think that's exactly what we're
going to see at some point in time if
not right now yes sooner rather than
later but we'll see when that comes
around casey what do you think of
bannon's defense and how do you think it
will play out at the end of the day
oh that's a weak defense if there's some
constitutional issues or privileged
issues you show up you respond to that
subpoena you show up with counsel allow
counsel to raise the proper objections
preserve it for the court and then make
the appropriate ruling but you just
don't disregard a subpoena
if you do then you have to reap the
consequences i had a case before where i
subpoenaed a
law enforcement officer and this was a
virtual depot and he refused to turn on
his camera so i abruptly ended the
deposition i filed my appropriate motion
and my rule to show cause and a host of
officers in his defense showed up for
support but bottom line the judge made
its ruling you answer to that subpoena
and you follow the law so no one is
above the law seems like a procedural
issue that bannon's going to have a
similar issue with thank you for that
insight on that story when we come back
elaine maxwell is headed to federal
court we look ahead to the former
socialites trial and examine this week's
jury selection process
welcome back to law and crime daily a
lengthy jury selection is expected in
the trial of socialite elaine maxwell
accused of facilitating and
participating in sex crimes involving
minors this week a u.s federal judge
began screening more than 200 potential
jurors in the case 59 year old maxwell
is charged with six felonies including
conspiracy to entice minors to engage in
illegal sex acts and transportation of a
minor to engage in an illegal sex act
these charges stem from a relationship
with long-time companion jeffrey epstein
who was arrested on federal charges of
sex trafficking in 2019. federal
prosecutors say maxwell helped epstein
groom girls as young as 14 years old for
sexual abuse and sometimes participated
in the abuse maxwell pled guilty to all
charges and has been held without bond
in a brooklyn jail
the trial is set to begin on november
29th law and crime's adam classfeld will
be at the courthouse with the daily
updates
casey just a quick question she's pled
not guilty to those charges the judge is
questioning 200 prospective jurors to
get 50 qualified jurors to then get 12
jurors and six alternates after seeing
the written house and mcmichael and
brian trial how do you think selection
here will play out
well obviously the facts are totally
different however she is a socialite so
this is a high profile case the question
now becomes whether these allegations
the prosecution has sufficient evidence
to prove these allegations was she just
a socialite that was just doing or as
instructed by mr epstein a dead man
can't talk so it's her word against his
or did she know more so the prosecution
is going to have to tie those loose ends
together in order to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt that she was an active
participant and knew more than what
she's saying
makes a lot of sense in that aspect
terry what do you think are the
difficulties of jury selection in this
type of case against elaine maxwell
well like casey has said this is a very
high profile case
chances are all of the potential jurors
know about the case and they're going to
have their biases one way or the other
they're going to have very polarizing
issues in this case there are a lot of
people who are in support of the metoo
movement they're in support of the
time's up movement and they have their
opinions about that and when they go
through that vordier they're going to
have to ask very detailed questions i
expect that the questionnaire is going
to have specific questions about what do
they know about the case how are their
feelings about the metoo movement have
they ever been involved in this type of
case personally and they've probably all
heard about the weinstein and bill cosby
cases and that's something too that i
think is going to affect the jury
selection and so it's going to take time
and you're going to need people who have
time to deal with this long trial
absolutely and thank you both and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you